painful infertility growing facial hair
suffering with acne and struggling to
lose weight PCOS is one of the most
common yet one of the most life-altering
conditions of Our Generation so if
you're part of the 1 in 10 with a
diagnosis and you're wondering what the
hell you should be eating go get your
favorite hormone healthy snack and watch
this hey everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome
to Abby's kitchen
[Music]
foreign
shout out to my colleague Erin Davis for
assisting on the research in this video
Aaron is a fellow Rd and diabetes
educator practicing from a weight
inclusive lens so if you are struggling
with your own blood sugars or PCOS
diagnosis definitely reach out she's
amazing I'm going to be leaving her
contact and links below also check out
my full disclaimer in the description
and I also want to make a quick note
that for Simplicity in repetition of my
own speech I will be referring to folks
with uteruses as women though I fully
acknowledge that folks who identify as
men may also have PCOS and finally you
can also find a link to my new free
downloadable HCC ebook and my ltk page
if you're wondering what I'm wearing in
my videos okay before we get into it
raise your hand if you played Yahtzee as
a kid like Yahtzee plus pizza in my
childhood Prime grade 5 Friday family
night I was so cool I know so I was
super excited to play Yahtzee With
Buddies so this is is a reimagined
version of the classic Yahtzee game
where you get to play in different
tournaments and game modes to win
different rewards I guess it's all
virtual you can play with other family
and friends or players elsewhere in the
world you can also interact through the
chat function so you can like break or
tease them and then you can win game
stickers and prizes my favorite prize is
the scratchers which are literally like
the lottery tickets that my grammy used
to buy me except for every single card
is a winner and you can also customize
your dice to whatever color scheme that
you like as you get more advanced it's a
really great nostalgic game to unwind
with anytime anywhere while still
keeping my brain challenged and engaged
I also love the family feast because you
get to compete with other families and
if you're super competitive like me it
is strangely satisfying I may or may not
be reading winning strategies on Reddit
so if you're looking for a new relaxing
end of day ritual you can download Yazoo
With Buddies using my link in the
description it really helps my channel
if you use that specific link so so head
to the description box to download it
today okay we're gonna make some protein
pancakes while we do this super quick
PCOS or polycystic ovarian syndrome is
essentially an imbalance of normal
reproductive hormones resulting in a
regular menstrual cycles excess facial
hair acne weight gain and infertility
more than half of women with PCOS will
also have diabetes or pre-diabetes by
the time they're 40 so there is of
course an interest in managing symptoms
early I get a lot of questions about
what to eat and avoid PCOS because we do
know that diet can play a role in
symptom management but in my experience
a lot of experts on the internet they
just love to prey on vulnerable folks
who are really just quite desperate for
symptom relief especially when perhaps
conventional medicine hasn't been so
much help the result is that we see a
laundry list of foods that you're
allegedly supposed to cut out to heal
your hormones
get time for that so so let's talk about
what influencers love to tell you is
toxic for PCOS and what the research
actually says a very important part of
this conversation about PCOS is
inflammation and influencers love to say
everything is inflammatory even though
at times it's clear that they don't
actually know exactly what that means
but in the context of PCOS we tend to
see higher levels of chronic low-grade
inflammation largely related to what we
call Advanced glycation end products AKA
age hold that thought I gotta blend
so what was I saying EGS yes these are
pro-inflammatory molecules that are
found in elevated levels in people with
diabetes insulin resistance PCOS and
other inflammatory diseases like
arthritis and Ages come directly from
our diet in folks with PCOS specifically
the higher your age exposure the greater
your risk of insulin resistance ovarian
dysfunction and obesity so now that you
have a little bit of background let's
talk about PCOS Public Enemy Number One
sugar and carbs so the sister Community
loves to hate on carbs likely because of
the not wrong assumption that carbs
stimulate insulin and insulin levels
tend to be elevated in PCOS so this has
some Merit so a systematic review of the
literature found that diets that are low
glycemic index AKA they don't raise
blood sugars quickly because they're
typically lower in carb or rich in
higher fiber carbs tended to improve
insulin resistance fasting insulin total
cholesterol LDL cholesterol total
testosterone and waist circumference
compared to diets that were high GI
another review suggested that a low
fiber highly smoke index diet was
strongly correlated with inflammation
which in turn can also affect fertility
hold it let's blend
foreign
so we also know that high glycemic index
diets do tend to increase the risk of
acne which is already a common concern a
lot of folks with PCOS so yes a diet
that is lower on the glycemic index
obviously is beneficial for this
particular population but this is a big
butt I like big butts and I cannot lie
low GI doesn't have to mean you can't
have carbs you have to go keto as so
many influencers out there insist
so this study for example compared a
high fiber low GI diet to a generally
healthy diet with the exact same amounts
of carbs protein fat and fiber so both
diets contained 50 percent of carbs
that's like 250 grams of carbs so it's
definitely not keto but the low GI group
carbs were like less refined higher
fiber options that help to balance those
blood sugars and despite having all
those carbs the low GI group still saw
improvements in insulin control and as I
discussed in my video on Sugar Sugar
alone is not the cause of insulin
resistance or in this case PCOS it often
comes down to what are we eating with
our sugar AKA are we dressing up those
naked carbs with Hunger crushing
compounds to reduce the insulin response
and it also comes down to how those
carbs are affecting our energy balance
and our body weight so yes you can have
carbs you just want to choose higher
fiber complex carbs or make them into
hunger crushing combos more often to
improve satiety which reduces the risk
of weight gain and also helps to
stabilize our insulin now
let's talk about another commonly
shunned Food Group in this community
Dairy so if sugar is like king of bad PR
Dairy is the spare to the air and is
often called out for being
pro-inflammatory in the PCOS Community
but interestingly the research does not
support all this shade not towards all
Dairy at least so one of the main
concerns is that Dairy will exacerbate
hormonal acne and yes we do see an
association between Dairy and acne you
know Dairy is thought to increase the
hormone insulin growth factor one which
can cause a bump in insulin levels and
antigen hormones which can then cause
acne but this Association was largely
seen with fat free or low-fat milk not
full fat milk or fermented dairy like
cheese and I don't know about you guys
but I will trade like cheese for skim
milk any day of the week we also tend to
see the same pattern with fertility
outcomes and different types of dairy so
research has linked the consumption of
low-fat and non-fad dairy to increase
risk of an ovulatory infertility whereas
consuming full that Dairy actually
reduced the risk and if we look at the
official fertility diet developed from
the nurse's health study data we see
that their ideal diet includes higher
fat dairy products like yogurt and
cheese so now you don't have to cut out
Dairy if it brings you Joy but choose
things like full-fat yogurt and higher
moisture high protein cheeses like
mozzarella or cottage cheese like I'm
doing right here which contain lower
levels of he compared to aged cheeses
like parm I gotta wash my hands
next let's talk about gluten and
thankfully this one is gonna be quick so
again this one comes down to the
assumption that wheat or gluten is
inflammatory which may be true for folks
with Celiac or gluten intolerance but if
we do see this Association it's likely
more to do with the choice in wheat
products being more refined or higher
glycemic index than the gluten protein
itself there is zero evidence that
gluten contributes to PCOS yet there is
research that a gluten-free diet tends
to have lower nutritional value compared
to traditional diets so typically
gluten-free alternatives are lower in
fiber and higher on the glycemic index
which may actually result in higher
insulin levels in inflammation which can
then exacerbate PCOS symptoms so this is
obviously quite individualized but if
you are not Celiac or gluten intolerant
I suggest choosing higher fiber grains
whatever you like with or without gluten
and then just like move on ignore the
gluten haters it's gonna be all right as
for foods that may be worth limiting
with PCOS one would be highly processed
fried foods which contains some of the
highest levels of Ages and are linked to
ovulation dysfunction red meat is
another one which again has some of the
highest levels of Ages especially when
cooked on super high Heats like on a
barbecue or on a grill and then finally
alcohol which can potentially
dysregulate estrogen progesterone levels
can also cause blood sugar fluctuations
and potentially can reduce fertility
even five drinks a week has been
associated with reduced chance of
getting pregnant so now we've debunked
the don'ts and we've discussed what
ideally we might want to consider
limiting but let's talk about what
actually matters to nutrition to me at
least and that is what we want to add so
as you guys know I have an additive
approach to nutrition because I just
think that focusing all the time on what
we need to take away shifts us into
scarcity mentality which puts us at an
even greater risk of overeating which in
the case of PCOS would typically
exacerbate a lot of negative symptoms so
here are some key things that I want you
guys to focus on number one focus on
plant-based Foods so you don't have to
look up the glycemic index of everything
you eat nor do you have to Google its
age content if we focus on getting in a
variety of colorful plant-based foods
like fruits and vegetables we will end
up with more fiber and more antioxidants
that together can fight inflammation and
also reduce the insulin response fiber
as I always talk about also increases
satiety which will then help with Weight
Management number two lean protein so I
talk about it all the time for good
reasons protein is King in this Thai
hierarchy it's also associated with
weight control and when paired with
carbohydrates it can help to flatten
that blood sugar response and this is
why it is a key feature of my Hunger
cushion combo for everyone but it's
particularly important for folks with
insulin resistance so think things like
legumes poultry fish tofu cottage cheese
Greek yogurt ETC number three healthy
fats you guys know you guys knew I was
gonna say it
um but we know Omega-3s are
anti-inflammatory and have also been
shown to help improve insulin resistance
in folks with PCOS so I really do
encourage people to incorporate more
fatty fish flax hemp walnuts Etc to get
in that daily dose so as you guys can
see we're talking about my Hunger
crushing combo right fiber Protein
healthy fats it does not need to be more
complicated than that now when it comes
to supplements for PCOS I'm a big
supporter episode moments for really
anyone especially for those who have a
particular health condition because I
think in a lot of cases it can help you
reach better food Freedom by removing
the burden of having to make your diet
perfectly every day so some supplements
that we have some evidence to support
for PCOS include inositol curcumin
vitamin D CoQ10 probiotics berberine and
as we mentioned Omega-3s finally getting
in adequate sleep and daily exercise are
also key evidence-based PCOS management
tips so I hope that helps clear the air
on what might be worth you focusing on
if you're struggling with PCOS and you
know a reminder that PCOS is highly
individualized so what works well for
one person won't work for another person
and vice versa a lot will just depend on
your symptoms your hormone levels your
sensitivity Etc so always speak to a
healthcare provider like my colleague
Aaron who again I'm going to be leaving
the information for or below but on that
note that's all that I have for you guys
today if you like this video please be
sure to give it the thumbs up bananas up
knives up whatever leave me a comment
below on any questions that you have or
any other nutrition questions or
concerns that you'd like me to do a
video on don't forget to check out my
new free Hunger crush and combo ebook
below and I'll see you next time on
Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]